dérangère viennot vous aviez signé la
pétition qu'on appelle depuis la
pétition signée par catherine deneuve
qui était justement une pétition qu'ils
essayaient dans les justes après
laffaire weinstein de complexifier un
peu et ça avait été extrêmement mail
reçu l époque de on avait 10 et vous
vous aimez dû faire harceler c'est ça je
crois était la tribune qui s'intitulait
les femmes des femmes libérées à notre
parole voilà une autre parole à jupiter
vous mettre au ban de la société et qui
a été écrite par cinq femmes essayé par
santos enfin 95 autres et puis ces cinq
femmes évidemment et qui est très vite
devenu la tribune de catherine deneuve
lorsqu'elle l'avait signé et dans
laquelle ces femmes s'inquiétait de des
dérives du mouvement mais tous donc elle
ne mettait pas en cause la légitimité ou
est l'intérêt de ce mouvement qui était
enfin d'écouter les femmes parce que
personnellement je pense que les femmes
ont toujours parlé juste on les écoutait
pas à ce sujet maintenant on les écoute
et avec cette tribune encore plus mais
le problème était que c'était eux
c'était un regard un peu nuancé sur la
situation pire que les dérives demi tous
étaient effectivement condamné des
agresseurs les montrer du doigt et les
livrer à la justice
ça ne peut être que positif mais mettre
dans le même panier
donc des agresseurs qui ont commis des
viols les agressions graves et les gars
dans le métro qui vous colle une main
sur les fesses c'est excessif parce que
il n'y a pas de raisons pas faire du cas
par cas dans ce domaine là comme on en
fait partout ailleurs surtout en terme
de justice et cette tribune a été très
mal reçus parce que je pense à elle a
été très mal eu voire très peu lu d'une
part parce qu'elle était payante enfin
elles étaient en accès payant au monde
et alors ça c'est un autre débat
pourquoi le monde l'avait vu la question
n'est pas là la question c'est pourquoi
les gens ne veulent pas payer pour
obtenir les informations de qualité
c'est pas ça la vraie question de courir
que si vous avez dans votre chez votre
boulanger que vous demandez un pari
gratuit va pas vous donner par contre
vous trouvez normal de lire le monde ou
un autre média gratuitement mais bon ça
c'est un autre débat
et pour revenir à cette tribune donc
elle a été très mal interprété et
surtout il a été relayé en fait ça fait
boule de neige plus l'été relayé plus
elle était déformée et est ce que ses
signataires qualifié de liberté
d'importuner c'est-à-dire importuner
dans le dictionnaire ça veut dire être
maladroit avec quelqu'un être un peu
lourdingue
lagacé on l'embêté ça veut pas du tout
dire lui connaît là mon panier mais ça a
été transformé en droit de harceler et
donc évidemment et très justement le bon
peuple océan didier parce que c'est mal
de harceler quelqu un et deux et de se
frotter dans l'exemple parfait de ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est à dire
simplification manic et isation du monde
à se soigner avec moi ou si vous n'êtes
pas avec moi vous êtes mon aîné je vous
tuerai acidité l'ambiance d'aujourd'hui
c'est compréhensible aussi dans la
mesure où on a tellement d'informations
à disposition qu'on peut pas tout les
1,6 million peut pas toutes les lire et
donc si si l'opinion est déjà toute
faite et qu'on nous la livre ainsi c'est
quand même beaucoup plus confortable et
je n'exclus pas de ce genre de personne
de l'adopter de la faire sienne se
l'approprier et de s'indigner quand
quand il ya matière à s'indigner et la
manière dont elle a été présentée cette
tribune en effet donné matière à
s'indigner
moi si on dit ça ne c'est pas grave on
frotte dans le métro ou compte mettre
une main au cul ou contraire ça dans la
rue basse à des pompes par moi j'ai pas
envie donc oui super m'indigner c'est
normal mais la façon de la présente et
qui a été en effet très manichéen on a
les gentils gentils femmes d'un côté et
les méchants harceleur de l'autre a fait
que ça s'est complètement emballé et
qu'on est passé à côté d'un débat et
c'est vraiment très dommage parce que
maintenant le débat est faussé on marche
sur des oeufs on a toujours peur de dire
un truc qui va être mal interprétés
parce que on va pas chacun au fond des
choses on se contente de recevoir une
info et de se dire bon bah je vais
prendre ça là et pieds au lieu de
réfléchir je vais m'en servir et la
livrer aux autres pour créer un nouveau
débat
[Musique]